that is begim tojan NOA after a crazy
game against TV abrahamian begim
congratulations welcome back to the show
tell us about the game because it felt
smooth at the beginning you got that
exchange up it didn't feel like you have
any problems but then that swinging
attack came in uh your Direction with H5
H4 what were you worried at that
time uh to be honest at first I thought
after H5 I can even play H4 I have so
many defensive moves so I didn't really
care about it even Queen A4 Queen B4
wasn't necessary like I just had an
exchange up it's not an easy position to
play of course uh but I did so many
moves that I didn't have to do to let
this
attack and then I don't know even after
a it wasn't easy I mean we were looking
at it with wasn't easy at
all no absolutely I'm not sure about
Queen A4 Queen B4 MH uh the problem is
that I didn't know how uh yeah I I
thought probably Queen C2 or Knight D2
is most logical move but I don't know
why I played Queen A4 Queen B4 I
immediately regretted it I'm I'm like
I'm just giving away a tempo for no
reason table yes exactly their only idea
is to play H uh H5 H4 that's why it
didn't make
sense and it was at this point when she
infiltrated with her Knight on H2 now
things are starting stting to look
dangerous for
you yeah before I played Rook E1 Knight
F1 I calculated this line and some for
some reason I thought I should be fine
after uh King G2 what I played during
the game uh then I just realized t t and
then like after Rook H1 she had to play
King D7 immediately that's what I missed
King d s and I cannot take on h8 and I
don't have any counter play to leave the
f file potentially open so that she can
go Rook to f8 followed by E3 yeah to
force you to open up that the thing I
just cannot take on h8 that that's why I
was like I felt like my position should
be fine uh when I was calculated I
totally Miss King D7 yeah yeah King to
D7 was the key
move and when she didn't spot it did you
get a a new burst of energy at that
point I was like I saw Rook AG Rook for
idea before as well so this was my uh uh
like initial calculation I thought I'm
getting this position I should be fine
at least I have a draw because the king
is very weak yes so that's why King D7
was so important for her but here then I
I thought okay I have only one trick
after Rook H4 she needs to find Queen E8
which is not that hard but if she finds
ke Queen E8 then I will make a draw if
she doesn't anything else is uh losing
for her that's why I just decided to try
this uh like last option and it worked
out and it worked out because after
Queen to F6 Queen to H5 there just
simply no more ways to defend against
this uh connection of the queen and the
Rook begging congratulations back to
back victories two and a half out of
three this is a good start for you keep
it up and we'll see tomorrow thank you
congratulations bam indeed